explain why these squares are minimum
when and then they give you an angle for
theta value for thinner okay now can we
just pause and think about before we
bought it to the algebra what this has
to do with the rest of the question what
if physically beans right have a look at
the same page back in part to back up
our to the idea is that theta this is
the angle you're actually shooting out
right clearly it has boundaries right I
mean if you actually want to get the
bomb in it has boundaries you can't
throw feet are below alpha why not cuz
then you get doesn't matter how hard you
throw that ball right you can throw them
with infant of Aussie and it will still
go underneath the hoop so no point okay
in the same way you can't throw any
bigger than pile onto why not because
then you'd be throwing it away from them
okay so we've got we've got values that
are astray out there but we've just
noticed that for either one of those
boundaries right alpha or pie on to if
you used either of those they'd have to
throw with new falou velocity right so
there's some spot in between where we
get this sweet spot and that's what
they're searching for right when V
squared is a minimum okay look at all
the pieces that you've got to go okay
you're looking for V squared to be a
minimal to be a minimum okay now look at
everything you've established looking
like the page and a half of working
you've gone okay you were v squared to
be a minimum and remember v square is 5d
on now i have a name for this
denominator down and i know a lot about
this theme it's f of theta now we want V
squared to be a minimum which means f of
theta ought to be a maximum okay file
that away Oh file that away now we're
ready to solve this question okay think
you think about it think about whe whe
it's the same logically applied over
here right you want the whole thing to
be small that means you need the
denominator to be big or vice versa if
that was
water ok so I'm going to take their
value right this is part five the last
one when theater is this value that
they're supplying when this is the case
I know something about 10 alpha 10 2
theta right just like this this is how I
got to hear right this also means this
does that make sense so if that's the
case 10 to 10 g there yeah and 23 2 10
alpha is equal to negative work but if
that's the case that also applies
something else back about f of theta or
more specifically f dash right where did
this come from yeah good it came from
this guy right you see how we're
climbing back up the logic that we
remove it all these plateaus effort to
get through so if that's the case
therefore F dash fina is 0 so I have a
stationary point but remember what I was
trying to establish I was trying to say
something particular that of theta I
want it to be a maximum so therefore I
can't it's not enough to know it's a
stationary point I have to know what
kind of stationary point it is ok so
tell me we've got two methods for
determining nature which what would you
like me to use hey guys yes a second
opinion
oh no guys on another horror horror slow
down slow down yeah have a look at this
guy right have a look is this hard to
differentiate not at all you've got
cosines and side that admittedly some
since looking at me like oh no it looks
terrible cuz they look at this guy which
doesn't matter why not it's a constant
okay I'm gonna differentiate okay use
the second derivative now of course if
you went by the table values that's fine
okay you're going to encounter some
problems whichever way you go i'm going
to no.8 them but i'm just going to
safely outset I think the problems you
have to deal with end up easy with the
secondary of the mid the first week
aside from even the differentiate so
let's go ahead and let's work out what
if Double Dash is equal to cos to be
second to go her breath your drug okay
what happens here but have a tea I'm
gonna get the tan out for out the front
thank you yeah okay yeah I've got my
second derivative and I've got a value
to test the second derivative for right
so I'm going to say therefore f double
dash of that guy is going to be equal to
okay now know it no I have a 2 theta 2
theta so I need to double this thing
right it looks to be like I'm going to
sine of alpha plus PI on to and that is
a two there cos of alpha plus piloted
okay now like I said being at this what
you're like oh no I regret everything
maybe I should get my teddy values ok
I'm going to stay with this let me try
justified for you ok suppose you went
for your table of values suppose you
want your tailored nails I'm not even
going to do the whole thing but what you
need is to say I've got my value of
theta I've got my F dash and then for
this value I don't can be 0 and then for
this value at this way I've got five
something here now I've labored the fact
you come just so it's positive right you
actually need a value there ok problem I
don't know I can't evaluate that I don't
know what alpha is right I can't push
this into my calculator ok so I'm going
to have to reason through what alpha is
and I have restrictions on after as well
to be able to say not only what's is
supposed to be by the way f what am I
looking for I what oh I want this to be
a laxative right so I want this it was
it oh I miss v- I'm gonna have to say
that about both of those things ok here
i just have to deal with one value ok
just have to do with one so i think this
is going to be a lot easier to work so i
am going to take up I can't affect
takeouts factor to the two doesn't
matter to me what that is is the
psychics are looking [ __ ] cavity here
ok now the sign of this thing we're used
to something nice a numerical an easy
but this is not nice and it's not be
very cool either ok so there are three
parts I'm gonna do with one two three
and they all change sign dependent on
what Alfred okay now think for a moment
what am I wanting I want this to be I
want this to be a max which means what
about all the sides of these things if I
want this to be a max let's figure out
this this thing just think about the
logic presenting this thing I want to be
a minimal that means this thing I want
to be an accident that is this thing I
want to be concave
down so I want this to be negative okay
that's what I'm after right so think
about this way the easiest way would be
think about each of these within the
domain info for alpha okay what's the
domain you know foul okay you ready I
load your three graphs for you i love
you follow with me then i need to be
beautiful but they need to be enough to
argue about these things okay so i'm
going to draw a graph one graph to graph
three because there are three pieces
okay these just have to be good enough
for me to argue from okay sine of alpha
plus pi 0 2 I know what sign looks like
what happens when I have whatever papaya
to I'd shifted to the left okay so signs
normally like this right whoops right
there right so I'm gonna have to move to
the left by PI on to that's cause right
okay from not a pilot West pilot ood on
here 0 into there all right that's piled
to okay so therefore in the domain I'm
interested here this guy is positive
thumbs up okay so i'm going to write
that down for this domain sine of alpha
plus x 2 is positive that's really good
because that means i need to worry about
this anymore if that's positive minus 2
times 8 is negative so that their
problems for me okay let's have a look
at these guys tear off on just end up in
black with me okay I just I'm just
worried about this first quadrant right
02 plan to and that's very very positive
right so therefore i can say cool 10
alpha is also going positive that that
means i need for this to be negative
right because I've got positive positive
this is baby David allies up in some
trouble ok so I'm going to graph this me
I know what caused looks like but then I
need to shift it pilots you to the left
right so it's gonna look like by this
sign isn't it right and look with pile
too it's here ok does that make sense so
within this debate that I'm interested
in breathe a sigh of relief cause all
alpha plus
you must be negative does that make
sense so by reasoning here all of my
pieces are negative therefore f double
dash at that particular value is going
to be 40 great I concave down um maximum
10 point okay well done take a breath
you did all the hard parts you have
quite answer the question what do I need
to do to tie this off ok so if F feeder
is a maximum right there 45 d on FB i--
is a bit of a does that make sense I
guess the UH you don't need this
language but what's going on v square
and f of theta are inversely
proportional to each other one gets
bigger the other one gets smaller okay
so therefore V squared is minimized and
if you minimize the square or something
you've minimized the thing itself right
they also these two answers I did that
so I don't even worry about megha sir Oh
an extra one okay